como maestro de matemáticas a menudo lo
más complicado es asignarles un nuevo
nivel un alumno quizás lo acabe en 30
segundos y otros no terminado el primer
ejercicio no tenía idea cómo iban a
reaccionar los niños y pensé que se
podían aburrir mucho sentados frente a
la computadora trabajando por su cuenta
hora y media cada día
nos sorprendimos por lo mucho que les
gustó totalmente concentrados por hora y
media cada día incluso les dábamos
descansos y algunos ni siquiera querían
tomar lo hace divertidas las matemáticas
nosotros podemos fácilmente subestimarlo
y pensar que ellos lo van a ver como
algo sin chiste y aburrido pero a ellos
les parece divertido supongo que porque
es diferente de la enseñanza normal
porque es tecnología que para ellos es
perfectamente normal en su casa pero
hasta cierto punto nosotros no hemos
incorporado esta tecnología en el salón
de clases una mamá me dijo que su hija
se sentía muy insegura con las
matemáticas y solo lo habíamos usado por
unos días pero dijo que ya estaba
teniendo mucho éxito y mucha más
confianza porque estaba trabajando a su
propio nivel y no se estaba comparando
con sus compañeros podemos monitorear
los podemos ver si están batallando y
podemos ir discretamente y ayudar a los
que les cuesta trabajo ni siquiera saben
que nosotros podemos ver lo que están
haciendo así que ayudamos a esa niña sin
que tuviera que levantar la mano eso es
genial y sí que podías ver que su
confianza creció durante la semana y la
mamá dijo que ha sido muy bueno para
ella me gustó que en can academy cité a
tórax con una pregunta solo vas al vídeo
y el maestro es bueno cuando lo acabas
sabes cómo hacerlo y me gustó como el
maestro nos puso los retos para que no
fueran muy difíciles son muy fáciles
sino en el nivel correcto me gustó que
es trabajo individual por tu cuenta
aprendí a hacer cosas nuevas ecuaciones
diferentes y cosas que no sabía antes y
ahora las aprendí y me gustó hay vídeos
por si te a tórax para que si no sabes
cómo hacer algo vas al vídeo y te enseña
cómo hacerlo y cuando acaba ya sabes
cómo y puedes resolver el reto sin
problemas
les da confianza incluso les pedimos que
nos evalúen durante todo el curso
simplemente les da mucha confianza poder
trabajar a su propio nivel y tener éxito
les saque mucho más provecho de lo que
esperaba puedo ver que tiene mucho
potencial antes de usarlo hubiera dicho
que no hay manera de que eso funcione en
el salón porque a los niños nunca les va
a interesar eso por más de media hora
llegó en las mañanas y conecto las
computadoras y las preparo el asunto es
sacarlas prender las prepararlas
tenerlas listas para usar y el tiempo
que se toma si haces eso a la mitad del
día desperdicias mucho tiempo pero por
el otro lado puedo ver que si funciona
para todos los niños sin importar su
nivel tenía unos cuantos niños que
estaban atrasados académicamente y pensé
que no lo iban a aceptar pero en
realidad les gustó mucho algunos están
volando los más adelantados están
volando probablemente le dedican tiempo
también en casa algunos vienen y te
cuentan de todo lo que han aprendido en
la semana cosas nuevas todo el tiempo y
mejores apenas esta mañana les pregunté
alguien ha aprendido algo nuevo que no
supieron antes y dijeron que sí eso es
muy interesante el que los niños vean el
proceso matemático como algo creativo y
divertido es quizá un nuevo punto de
partida para muchos de ellos y algo a lo
que no están acostumbrados en el
ambiente escolar típico creo que es uno
de los puntos más interesantes vamos a
donde creo que tenemos mucho que
aprender aquí y me interesa mucho ver si
las lecciones aprendidas esta semana en
algún momento podemos aplicarlas en todo
el sistema escolar creo que tiene un
potencial enorme para tener éxito en las
escuelas irlandesas hay personas
brillantes trabajando en el centro
galway y la fundación o sullivan también
está apoyando así que ha sido increíble
en este sentido y está tomando impulso
en varios salones el cielo es el límite
esto va a despegar